[Music]
our Lord and Liege was the soul of my
sister of the three sisters who founded
the sable Church Alfreda
was the eldest and their leader together
with the hollows of LAN door they fought
to usurp the first flame for hollow kind
and you of course were part of that in
one of the endings but before you came
along it appears that there was another
who tried to usurp the flame but failed
Alfreda a poor wench turned to ash who
would abandon Lundell uncondition words
are undead who failed to link the flame
and in the opening cutscene I personally
think that we see the soul of cinder
dragging and cremating one of those
failures one of those undead that failed
to take him on and turned into ash and
these are failures that can rise again
when the link of fire is threatened
failures like El freedom failures like
you after her failure Alfreda truly
distanced herself from the church don't
forget we know that you need to be very
forlorn to find this painted world so
it's possible that she found this place
in her despair and when she arrived she
didn't sit meekly by like so many other
creatures in this place no instead she
decided that this was a world and a
people that she wished to protect for
this world really is a reflection of the
outside and as a result it was a chance
for her to take a truly different path
on the outside the fire fades and a
great sacrifice triggers the rebirth of
this world and on the inside in the
painting the painting Falls to rot and
it's residence set it aflame to put an
end to the rot painting a new world for
themselves just after this happens both
places have a cycle of rebirth and on
the outside Alfreda died attempting to
break that cycle and usurp the flame and
after her failure she fights for the
exact opposite fate within the painting
she renounced everything and she fights
to keep things the way they are now to
embrace the rot the stagnation the
stasis to force her version of kindness
upon the residents of the painting how
this came to pass I know not but take
heed kindness can wear upon one's
principles and beyond the gate which
looks like it was broken in words as if
someone forced their way in his father
Arion del restorer over the painted
world or what's become with him anyway
Rishi
shrim Flickerman once the game
not enough bloody a cheating but flu
burn we must feel the bird-like core
viens refer to him fondly as the good
father which belies a close relationship
between the two of them I have a feeling
they don't think he can do any wrong
because they say this but that which
fooled the good father and buried to
Spain after we had all made up our minds
to that which fooled the good father on
the other hand Frida's soul says that
together with the good father
they chose rot over flame so did Ari and
L betrayed the world he painted or was
he bewitched as the core viens would
like to believe and so began this
terrible partnership Frida what is over
the father who strapped to his chair
flails himself to produce blood to
protect their secret and the secret is
the flame that they buried after all re
and L knew that their world was painted
with blood and he knew that only blood
could appease the flame it's rather the
same on the outside as well ours is the
blood that keeps the fire alive it's our
sacrifice and I think they're trying to
make a point here about that just
outside Frida sits waiting guarding Lord
of Hallows I know not the missteps which
led me to this painted world but thy
duty is all and thy duty lieth elsewhere
sweep all thought of us from thy mind as
thy kind always half
it is said that when the ashes are to a
flame will alight so Frida and Vilhelm
they want you gone because they're
hopeful that they can avoid conflict
between the two ashes for conflict could
easily prove that prophecy right and
roused the withering flame Phil helm
stands further out and he's likely the
person that yuria says stood by elf
Freda till the end in the shadows cast
by fire you look to be on Kindle no Bell
Tolls and yet you've slipped into the
painting in the outside of the filing
belt holes when the link of fire is
threatened and it awakens the
uncondensed at a bell is supposed to
draw an kindled into the painting or it
would if it wasn't buried in the snow
here I'd say that Vilhelm and el Freda
have something to do with it yo lady
ureas lord of hollows lady Frida has
spoken
is she not then Terry no longer and be
gone
carry on a lady urea and the londo serve
Vilhelm
renowned as a cold-blooded hangman once
served the three sisters of the sable
church he was however particularly loyal
to the eldest and yet the time came when
el Freda bowed him farewell she gave him
the Onyx blade this black twisted sword
that could in wreath itself with black
flame which is the flame that's molded
within all Freda is a weapon that's very
personal to her and this gift says one
must curiously though the item
description says that this sword was a
farewell gift the acceptance of which
signified bill Helms resignation from al
Frida's service and that's weird because
in the painting it seems as if he is
still in her service right
so I take this line to mean that he was
relieved of service to Alfredo's sable
church not to l Frieda in particular but
even after she failed to usurp the flame
if that is indeed what happened he
remains loyal it's so loyal that even
yuria asks us to remember his name so
loyal that he would guard the white
haired woman with his life and defend
her against all intruders I've seen your
kind time and time again every fleeing
man must be called every secret must be
unearthed such is the conceit of the
self-proclaimed seeker of truth but in
the end you like the stomach for the
agony it should bring upon yourself
let's talk about Frida's boss fight the
boss fights in souls that feature
resurrection I reckon they're the most
fitting in the series since our
character has that ability to come back
and kill them multiple times so why
can't they do that to Lorien and lothric
the abyss watches and now freedom who is
resurrected twice by the fire and the
second time when the father falls he
utters
[Music]
notice this line is in quotation marks
as he appears to be quoting the tale
that everyone in this painting repeats
multiple times when the ashes are to our
flame are lighter and as Freda is
resurrected by the flame I think and
maybe this is obvious but I think that
father arendelle interprets this tale or
prophecy as meaning when the answers are
to the black flame within Freda shows
itself because he'd much rather
interpreted that way than the
alternative which is to say that he'd
rather Freda alight than his world
beside a flame of course Freda really is
destined to fall to us in the end and
that's it we've met two founders of
disabled church now we've met el Freda
the eldest who lost herself in the
painting with Matt yuria
in search of the true Lord of Hallows
and we've yet to meet the youngest
sister Lillian assumedly this could be
her in the final cutscene right do you
reckon we'll go to land or it seems
logical because the usurping of the fire
that ending is one of the rare times and
ending has felt like the series is
progressing and with most of our
questions related to the nature of
hollowing and the origins of the undead
curse I could really seal on door
holding some answers but I've definitely
been wrong in my DLC predictions before
so let's just wait and say I am going to
be a bit more conservative with some of
my assumptions so I'll see you next time
Merry Christmas got it
[Music]
[Music]